hi I'm Theodore Kim I'm associate
professor of computer science here at
Yale University
and I co-lead the Yale computer Graphics
lab which we are in right now I
investigate a physics-based animation
problems for film and for video games
and for VR environments
one thing we've been interested in
lately is human hair you can see it's
just a bunch of strands if you really
look deeply at the math for computing
human hair it's actually really
formulated for very straight hair so
this is here you've probably seen
shampoo commercials where at the very
end somebody does a toss of their head
and there's a great wave of hair that
flicks back so most hair algorithms have
been developed for this kind of hair but
there's lots of kinds of hair there's
very curly hair and afro textured hair
this actually has not been examined
almost at all in computer Graphics so
right now we are developing algorithms
for realistically simulating the motion
of extremely tightly curled hair
one of the first things that we do is we
try to look at lots of references and
then we dig into the math
and we say what equations can we come up
with that will efficiently capture these
important visual features many of you
probably have seen the Pixar movie Soul
which actually has lots of Afro textured
and kinky hair in it simulating this
hair even for the people at Pixar it was
actually still quite difficult because
these tools they were not really made
for this type of hair hundreds of
researchers over decades around the
world have poured lots and lots of
effort into understanding precisely what
sort of math goes into this sort of
realistic depiction and this equivalent
effort has just not been invested into
afro textured and kinky hair yet so our
hope is that if we develop new math new
physics and new algorithms then maybe
next time around it'll be much easier to
make well actually what I really look
forward to is in the future when I watch
movies I don't feel oh I see they had to
make a sorry decision based on the
technology of straight hair they could
make any story choice that they wanted
to and there is just a huge diversity of
hair
[Music]